so the question is factorize this now I
can think off the top method there are
four ways to do this okay four ways to
do it there are two months assigned to
this which is kind of the issue okay now
one of the ways probably the fastest way
is to do this cross method
okay now I'll confess to you and I'll
explain why in a second I never ever
even as a math teacher
I never mastered this method okay and
the reason why I'm gonna come back to
original sort of question I keep asking
is it clear what you have done now it's
clear if you kind of like like what what
do any of these things mean well you
have to know what the method means in
order to explain it right and if you
don't it be like wow if you've never
seen this before you like that's just
it's just gibberish right it's some
numbers right and what do they have to
do anything now
therefore I go with my with my three
other ways with my three other ways of
doing it okay in order of least
preference
I think sarcastic about that backwards
for four I put here now I'll just
mention right it works to get numbers
right so if for instance this is not the
question but you arrive at this
quadratic try and do something else
right and so this is clearly not the
emphasis of the question because it's
the fastest you know thumbs up you'll
get a factorization assuming you're good
at right but if that's the actual
question mmm you arrived from this
straight to your line your ASR and
you're like wait then where'd that come
from
right and you might get you might get
two marks because it's hard and if you
just get that line and all of the
coefficients are right I'll give you a
thumbs up you just as equally might not
especially if especially if just to drag
give you some context because I can
understand how maddening it is where
it's like what do you mean sometimes you
get one and sometimes you get to answer
think back to when you're in learning
similar triangles some of triangles and
how do you prove the triangle is similar
if you do this line and this line and
this line and conclude and then a reason
and if you do not set it out exactly
like that then BAM out of your three
marching for sure lose one
now this fast-forward you learn kind of
similarly mainly in your nine
fast-forward to year 12 okay
when similarity produced up here in like
circle geometry blah blah blah blah blah
in this kind of question is similarity
the emphasis no it's not circle
geometries the emphases and other kinds
of dimensions so on okay so if your
similarity proof is not beautiful we're
gonna give a rip that's not the point of
the question will you lose them are
almost certainly not okay
whereas if you're over here there's a
big difference in fact it's like three
more marks on proving triangles are
similar right you guys would laugh if
you got three whole bucks for that in
your twelve okay so that that's why
there's a continuum here where the focus
shifts away right where you see this and
that's the whole question there is
strong evidence to you that I am looking
for you to demonstrate one of the
methods I've showed you right and this
usually isn't one of them so let's go in
reverse order the next the most Walker
way to do this is by the quadratic
formula okay now you'll keep in mind
well that's why it's option on the train
uh keep in mind that the quadratic
formula would come up with this K equals
blah blah blah blah and you'd have two
numbers okay but you can't you can't get
a cake without of this because it's not
an equation it's money you'll say
anything it's not equal to zero for
instance okay so what you'd have to do
with this with these numbers you get one
would you get three fifths and minus
five one three or something like that
okay you have to take that and you have
to put it into a factorized form right
so it's not only is the coordinate
formula long but this okay
ready here we go number two
yes in Reverse Oh No these kind kind of
equal okay so you kind of pick and
choose what you want okay but method
that any was mentioned using good London
which is parent which is parent okay if
you see this is a trinomial right yeah
three times but just as equally it could
be we're looking for or five or whatever
okay so if I gave you something like
this when you expand this out almost
certainly most of us instinctively will
go this times this and this this times
this this and you will get one two three
four terms out but when you think about
this right can you see that the term you
get out of this product and the term you
get out of this product will be like
terms right so that's why those two
terms become one right but you can
reverse that process right so what I
would do is I think it's twenty five of
nine right so you'd say fifteen K
squared minus twenty five K minus nine
okay yeah remember where I said these
come from they come from all look I
multiplied this and I multiply that
right so these things clearly must pair
up with these right is gonna be this
kind of thing happening right so if you
take factors out of this like we keep 25
a 9 because 25 will factor we 15 and
we'll just so happens the numbers are
the same but you would divide up
whatever this is into one part the
factors here and one part of fact is
there okay now where this is tricky
isn't that often with the numbers you
get you have multiple different options
but you start to see as soon as you
write it down you're right this line you
know oh I can't go any further because
I've picked the wrong pair of numbers
okay here let's see what happens
what should I do I can take out a 5 K
and not the front right which would
leave me with 3 K minus 5
okay now you didn't look at the
right-hand part of it that's my minus
sign to the wrong side besides that's no
problem so I'll just take a minus sign
out
so let's say minus three which would
leave me with surprise surprise 3k minus
five
okay don't go yet so there's your
factorization okay I will just before
you rise to roll for I'll allude to the
last method
I always show it to you remember if you
get something like this okay you're
thinking of two numbers what are the two
numbers supposed to do what the rules
are in your head they should multiply to
this and add to that right right so if I
change this this is not gonna work but
if I do if I change that I just put a
number out the front it works exactly
the same way with one difference I'm
still gonna search for a pair of numbers
that add to that but instead of a number
that multiplies to this I want a number
that multiplies to this that's it
that's all there is to it and you can
come up with that same pair of numbers
in here
I want a pair of numbers that add to
minus 34 and that multiply to 225 XR
minus 25 and minus 9